[Music]
before starting experiments on the
incandescent electric light system
many memorandums were drawn up as to a
general system
that would permit of the subdivision of
the lights
into small units and elegance to gas
jets
and with commercial economies superior
to the prevailing gas system
the reservoirs that if it wants to be
successful
all the units must be worked in month
long
this necessitated the creation of maps
of very high resistance
to diminish the enormous investment
in copper necessary
if low resistance labs were to be used
the necessity this this decision and
verifying hair like filament of the air
resistance material
on october 21st 1871
numerous experiments resulted in the
production of a small unit map
of comparatively enormous resistance
the filament being under conditions of
great stability
after the result i knew the problem
approached commercial solution
while these map experiments continued
other parts of the general system was
acted to be experimented upon
the dynamo has been invoked was
extremely inefficient
the laws approaching 50
due to some misunderstanding among
electricians which i never comprehended
however this these experiments produced
an animal of which 90 percent of the
energy was useful
then meters were measuring the current
were used by thousands of customers
and also a host
of accessories like underground converts
switches sockets etc were necessary to
make a complete system of distribution
all of which was accomplished
after the installation of the first
station new york other improvements were
added
such as a three-wire system
which reduced the coppery
conductor requirements more than fifty
percent
after this many central distributing
stations were in indonesia
in the days i had a high opinion of the
system
but i did not realize the stupendous
electrical industry of today
naturally i am gratified to feel that i
have been prudence to play a part in
this vast achievement
i am proud of electrical industry
of its vision current zeal and devotion
to the public service and i suspect
every american feels the same way about
it
it is a great reward for me and my
colleagues and co-workers many of them
still living that we have survived to
see the fruits of our neighbors
the record is wonderful but fine as it
is it can be made still better and i
have a feeling that in your hands it
will be
[Applause]
you